[Music]
it was step by step i started
decreasing my weights more and more in
crossfit and
it took me three years but i lost 30
pounds in three years
where you hold weight maybe
in your in your physiological or it may
be in your energetic body you know you
may have blocked solar plexus and that
affects your digestion your digestive
system and that makes your metabolism
slow down and you know that whole
process less efficient
keto it's not for the long term listen
i'll say this if you can do it long term
great but most people think it's super
defensive they're like
i lost i lost 40 pounds in the last 10
minutes i was like that's amazing tell
me how it goes for the next year
it's like if you can do it forever
fantastic personally i like going to
park having potato chips without feeling
like i'm a failure but that's just me
walking after you eat um i mean in the
meadow in the health and wellness they
call like post perennial you know so
it's it's super important um it's really
good for it's just really good to
to blunt that blood sugar response so
that um
it doesn't spike how can i satisfy
cravings before they hit
and ease myself like i'm all about that
gradual consistency because what we've
seen in research is consistency always
outpaces it's like these fad diets and
these these short pushes which bursts of
energy in a workout or bursts of like
changing your life can really motivate
you to clean it up and keep it clean
or at least elevate a little bit more
like the month or two after but i'm
looking for someone to make something a
lifestyle
when you look at the blue zones when you
look at areas where people are living a
disproportionately long period of time
you know nikoia and
sardinia and okinawa and loma linda and
all these blue zone hot spots around the
world
you do see no matter whether they're
more plant-based
no matter whether they're high carb low
fat high fat low carb no matter you know
the type of plants and herbs and spices
that they're using
key characteristics of each of those
populations that in sort of a venn
diagram overlap no matter what the diet
is and
those would include a
some element of fasting and protein
restriction on certain days of the week
or at certain periods of time during the
year such as a religious fast such as a
daily or or weekly like one day where
you're not eating protein or meats
perhaps a certain period of time each
spring summer winter and fall or you
might go four to five days eating a
lower calorie diet or doing more of like
a cleanse or a detox but basically this
idea that
autophagy or cellular cleanup or fasting
is woven into culture as part of the
diet
we also see that food is consumed in a
parasympathetic
low stress state
chewed
very very well and typically eaten with
people in a celebratory manner or in a
manner in which relationships are being
built big glorious family dinners
eating mindfully and chewing your food
paying attention as you cook a meal that
you're meditating over it and generating
you know positive energy and prayers and
gratitude over that food and not you
know sucking down a smoothie while
you're speeding down the freeway at 65
miles an hour on your way to work right
so food is consumed mindfully and often
in a celebratory fashion with people
just by slowly cutting back in weights
and being more lenient with my diet
because i was like eating a ton of nut
butters because
you know that was kind of where paleo
was at sure
nut butter doesn't work well for me and
my skin issues so why am i doing this
i'm gonna have some more potatoes
instead of having a higher fat so do you
think there was a big calorie shift or
do you think it was just
some sort of energetic freedom food
freedom i think both you know because
like it's one thing to change the food
and be like not mentioned that you're
eating drastically less calories or or
less calories um but sometimes i think
there's some energy behind it too of
just not getting attached too much not
thinking so much about the weight and
more about the
enjoyment more about the freedom less
punishment more flow well and it's less
cortisol then because you're not
stressing yeah so that's what i think
was one of the main things i definitely
obviously calories
are a huge part of uh weight loss but i
think that shift in uh stress hormone
that happened in my body by working out
less and by stressing less about food
yeah because i just i stopped thinking
about it all the time it didn't consume
my entire day when you say put the
energy into your food
that still is a little bit of a
confusing directive so maybe go through
the process of how exactly you do it so
so now you've connected right with that
feeling from doing your gratitude you
know your gratitude practice your
gratitude list you can feel how it feels
when you're super grateful about
something you love it so much right
right you're going to go downstairs to
your kitchen or maybe you don't have
stairs you're going to go to your
kitchen and now you're preparing
whatever it is that you're making
something to drink a water tea you're
making your food
when you're when i say put that energy
back into your beverage or your food
you're doing it with gratitude so you
can literally say i'm so grateful for
this lemon water because i know it's
going to heal and nourish me i'm so
grateful for this amazing spread you
know of of food from the farmers market
i'm so grateful i have a chance to make
breakfast for the person that i love
today or god i love coffee so much thank
god for this cup of coffee i mean
whatever it is that you do it's just
taking that moment but
and it could be you're saying thank
thank you it's honestly the easiest
thing to to do there's a few words that
are so powerful as we know i am so
powerful and thank you so powerful so
just being able to say that to
to your food or your beverage as you're
putting it back in or
if you're just prepping that's another
way just to acknowledge
that which is in front of you and
in a way you're just you're honoring
that you're honoring those carrots and
potatoes that you're preparing for
dinner just putting that energy back in
that way
you're literally sending that energy
back into the food
which changes the resonance you know of
the food which elevates it and then that
goes back into your body and actually
environmentally you're also elevating
you know the resonance the frequency
around you to go from multiple workouts
a week to just three but i found the
more i rested the more results i was
getting because i was building this
muscle but i was creating all this
inflammation and i was constant
constantly inflamed yeah and as i rested
that inflammation went down and then i
would see this like new muscle in my leg
or see this new muscle in my arm or see
my core more like i was finally able to
see these results
all by resting so we might just need to
address
your solar plexus you know and some key
foods to eat there and some key foods to
maybe like substitute out and it's less
adding on 30 minutes of exercise and
less you know about calories or um
or intake so which each person is a
little bit different i could eat a meal
that was like yeah chicken and spinach
kind of thing and it would spike my
blood sugar more than other meals and
i'm thinking like it's just chicken and
spinach and that's because you know
you're i mean your blood does it does
change with protein it's like fat's the
only thing that doesn't have any effect
um but uh but protein does have somewhat
of an effect and um and carbohydrate
carbohydrate has even more um so i'd say
make sure that you eat fat and protein
at the beginning of all your meals to
help with your blood sugar response with
food people are very quick to
make
they they're they like to reduce health
to nutrition that's all it's like well
it's just nutrition and then all they
think about is nutrition there's a lot
more to health
not to mention it's the relationship you
have with what you're putting in your
mouth if you're looking at the room
around you what everyone else is eating
you're like i wish i was having that i
wish i was having that if you're looking
or judging everybody basically they're
eating oh they're stupid they're gonna
die early they're gonna get cancer you
need a chill
you need to relax
have a donut and chill for a second
because this there's way more to life
than having such a reductionist view of
everything you're doing with food it's
like let's just show you